well I'm joined now by Bell Estes and
he's Labour's shadow business and
international trade minister very good
evening to you RBS have said they're
sorry the FCA have said that they're
possibly looking into taking further
action but that means they might also
not take further action is that good
enough
good evening is about 1,000 zuv
businesses were ruined people lost their
homes in some cases people killed
themselves this is a very very serious
matter I think it's highly significant
the police are investigating and the
release of the interim report today is
is a very big step forward but look even
the report admits that the totally wrong
priorities of the of what went on at RBS
grg so there's there's somewhere to go
but this is a very very important next
step okay it's an important next step
the FC obviously took a bit of
persuading to reveal these latest
findings but to be fair to them they
haven't held back today described
systemic mistreatment of customers
widespread wrongdoing would you agree
with what they found
certainly the reports I've heard from
quite a number of people who suffered as
a result of what happened at obvious are
entirely consistent with what the
interim report says today and I think
this is this is an important step but as
the report's author says we really need
to see the full report we need to see a
judge that inquiry and these things need
to happen you know given that the police
isn't at least are now investigating I
think it's really important the
information comes out for would that
need to be a judge led inquiry though if
the FCA had more teeth have more powers
to address wrongdoing like this whether
the FCA is the right body to have the
teeth is a good question I'm not sure
there that came to do so but certainly
there needs to be better regulation
there needs to be better support for
smaller businesses the one reason this
is so important is that relationships
between businesses and the banks are
really really bad at the moment and
unless the full truth comes out unless
it's established in full it's very
difficult to repair some of that damage
and we need to get lending going again
we need to support small businesses and
that's the role of the banks for the
good of the economy nobody trusts banks
anymore do they mean Trust has been
damaged right across the board and
that's exactly why it's so important
that the the
comes out in full because at some point
for the good of the country we need to
see the bank's playing their part again
nobody trusts banks I wonder does
anybody trust labor on brexit we saw the
Prime Minister today really trying to
press Jeremy Corbyn in the Commons on
what Labour's positions actually are cuz
you're in an easy position to criticize
what the government's trying to achieve
but actually she said you know what sort
of deal do you want do you want to be in
the single market do you want to be in
the customs union do you want free
movement you even want a second
referendum perhaps you could shed some
light because Jeremy Corbyn very evasive
this afternoon well Jeremy's role is to
question the Prime Minister in answer to
her statement and authority of that very
well the the point is that there are two
men in the Conservative Party now who
are pushing for a heart for a no brexit
No Deal brexit which would be disastrous
we'd see 34 to 40 percent tariffs on
dairy and meat 10% on cars we'd see the
hard border in Northern Ireland and I'm
specifically asking you where Labour
stands and some of these key issues
Kirsten has admitted today the Labour
Party is incredibly divided on a lot of
the key issues well I think the
important point is that we don't accept
there needs to be no deal we think it's
really important that the government is
negotiating hard accept a bad deal no I
wouldn't expect a bad deal that's why
we're calling for a vote in the House of
Commons people voted who voted leave
they didn't vote yeah that they think
they voted because they wanted to bring
back control tea to the United Kingdom
Parliament and not leave it in Brussels
but that meant they want parliamentary
sovereignty to be reestablished we've
seen the great so-called great repeal
bill being delayed yet again this week
and we're none the wiser on when that's
otherwise on whether or not the Labour
Party wants to be in the single market
well we we believe that we need to have
be members of a single market and a
customs union with the EU during a
transition period which appears so
number of times now will be as long as
necessary as it's needed and as short as
possible and after that period we've got
to have the best possible frictionless
arrangements with main trading partner
44% of trade is between the both of the
UK's with the
you it's vital we do everything in our
power to retain that it's got to be that
we have a deal negotiated with the EU
who looks after jobs and the economy
first and that's what we're for arguing
for well as to some really good to talk
to you thanks very much indeed